I mentioned in the opening lecture that
this course is going to be examined the
biblical Corpus from a variety of
different viewpoints and take a variety of
approaches, historical,
literary, religious, cultural,
and today we're going to
begin our appraisal of the
first portion of the Bible
as the product of a religious
and cultural revolution.
The Bible is the product of mines that
were exposed to and influenced by and
reacting to the ideas and
cultures of their day.
And as I suggested in the opening lecture
of Comparative Study of the literature
of the ancient Near East,
and the Bible reveals the shared cultural
and literary heritage at the same time
that it reveals great
differences between the two.
In the literature of the Bible,
some members of Israelite Society,
probably a cultural,
religious and literary elite broke
radically with the prevailing norms of the
day. They mounted a critique
of prevailing norms,
the persons responsible for the final
editing and shaping of the Bible somewhere
from the seventh to the fifth
or fourth century BCE, right?
We're not totally sure,
and we'll talk more about that,
but those final editors
were members of this group.
And they had a specific worldview and
they impose that worldview on the older
traditions and stories that
are found in the Bible.
That radical new world view
in the Bible was monotheism.
But why you might ask should the idea of
one God instead of many be so radical,
what is so different? What's different
about having the one God, um,
from having a pantheon of
gods headed by a superior God?
What is so new and revolutionary
about monotheism? Well,
according to one school of thought,
there isn't anything particularly
revolutionary about monotheism.
And the classical account of the rise
of monotheism that has prevailed for a
very long time runs as follows.
And I have a little flowchart
here to illustrate it for you.
The argument goes that in every society
there's a natural progression and
natural progression from polytheism,
which is the belief in many gods.
Usually these are personifications of
natural forces to Henno theism and no one
God or modality,
which is really the worship of one
God as supreme over other gods.
So not denying the existence of the other
gods, ascribing reality to them, but um,
isolating one as the Supreme God and
onto monotheism where essentially one
believes only in the reality of one God.
And in the 18th and 19th centuries,
this progression was viewed as an
advanced, which has an advance,
which is not very surprising because
the whole theory was put forward by,
um, scholars who were
basically western monotheists.
And these scholars maintain that
certain elements of biblical religion
represented pure religion,
religion evolve to its highest form,
no longer tainted by pagan and,
and polytheistic elements of
Canaanite religion generally.
So applying an evolutionary
model to religion carried
with it a very clear value
judgment. Polytheism was understood
as clearly inferior and primitive.
Manal tree was an improvement, right? It
was getting better, it was getting closer,
but monotheism was judged to be the
best and purest form of religion.
And that first,
the great archeological discoveries that
I talked about last time in the 19th
century seemed to support this claim that
Israelite monotheism had evolved from
Ancient Near Eastern Policy Ism cuneiform
tablets that were inscribed with the
great literature of
Mesopotamian civilizations were
uncovered and when they were
deciphered, they shed astonishing
light on biblical religion.
And these discoveries led to
a kind of parallel Romania.
That's how it's referred
to in the literature.
Scholars delighted in pointing out all
of the parallels in theme and language
and plot and structure between biblical
stories and ancient near eastern stories.
So more than a thousand years before the
Israelite legend of Noah and the Ark,
you have Mesopotamians
telling the story of Zeus,
Soulja or in some versions [inaudible]
who also survived a great flood by
building an arc on the instruction of
a deity and the flood destroys all life
and he sends out birds to scout
out the dry land and so on.
So with parallels like these,
it was argued,
it was clear that the religion of the
Israelites was not so different from the
religions have their,
they're polytheistic are pagan neighbors.
They also had a creation story.
They had a flood story.
They did animal sacrifices,
they observed purity.
Taboos is sort of like religion was
another ancient near eastern religion.
And they differed from their neighbors
only over the number of gods they
worshiped, one or many. It
was just a more refined,
more highly evolved version of
ancient near eastern religion. Well,
this a view,
this evolutionary viewer evolutionary
model was challenged by Amanda and has
killed Koufman Calvin in the 1930s.
And Kausmann argued that monotheism does
not and cannot evolve from polytheism
because the two are based on
radically divergent worldviews,
radically divergent
intuitions about reality.
And in a multivolume work, um, which
was later translated and abridged.
And you've got a selection of reading
from the translated abridgment.
So it's translated by Moshe Greenberg
and abridged version of his massive work.
The religion of Israel Koufman asserted
that the monotheism of Israel wasn't,
it couldn't be the natural outgrowth
of the polytheism of an earlier age.
It was a radical break with it.
It was a total cultural and
religious discontinuity.
It was a polemic against polytheism and
the pagan worldview that's implicit.
He says throughout the biblical text,
it's been said that Koufman replaces the
evolutionary model with a revolutionary
model. This was a revolution,
not an evolution. Now,
one advantage of Calvin's model is
that we avoid some of this pejorative.
We can avoid,
avoid some of the pejorative
evaluations of polytheism as primitive,
right? It's necessarily earlier in
primitive and [inaudible] and inferior.
There's simply positing the existence of
two distinct orientations to divergent
worldviews.
They each have their explanatory merits
and they each have their specific
problems and difficulties. It's not to
say that Calvin wasn't clearly judgmental,
but at least what the potential is
there for us to understand these as two
distinct systems. Um, each, again, as
I say with it's explanatory merits,
but as we'll see, some of the things
that monotheism, um, solves, um,
only invite other sorts of problems that
it has to wrestle with throughout it's
long life. Now in Calvin's
view, the similarities,
therefore,
between the Israelites and ancient
near eastern religion and cultures that
everyone was so busily
finding and celebrating,
these were in the end similarities in
form an external structure appearance.
They weren't essential similarities.
They different in content? Sure.
They both have animal sacrifice. Sure.
They both have ritual purity laws.
Sure they share certain
stories and legends.
But these have been adopted by
the Israelites and transformed,
transformed into vehicles that convey
the basic ideas of the monotheistic
worldview.
Uh,
so as similarity and form doesn't
mean a similarity in function.
And in this Calvin's anticipating
arguments made by anthropologists,
the ritual cult of the Israelites may
look like that of their neighbors,
but it functioned very differently.
It's purpose was drastically different
from that of Israel's neighbors.
The Israelites, like their neighbors
may have set up a king over themselves,
but Israelite monarchy differed from
Canaanite monarchy insignificant ways
because of their monotheism. These are
all things we will test and explore.
So the meaning and function of Israel's
cult of Israel's king of its creation
stories or any of its other narratives,
they derive from the place of those items
within the larger cultural framework
or worldview of Israel.
And that larger framework or
worldview is one of basic monotheism.
So let's turn then to cal [inaudible]
description of the fundamental distinction
between the policy is stick worldview.
And the revolutionary
monotheistic worldview that
took root in Israel. And, um,
I am going to be rehearsing and then
critiquing the arguments that are in that
hundred page reading that
I signed for you this week.
This is the only time something
like this will happen in the course.
And I do that because these ideas are
so fundamental and we are going to be
wrestling with them throughout the course.
So it's important to me that you absorbed
this stuff right from the beginning
and think about it and be
critical of it and engage it. Um,
Calvin's ideas are very important.
They're also overstated in some ways,
and that's why we're going to be wrestling
with some of these ideas throughout
the course.
So let's begin with Calvin's
characterization of what
he calls pagan religion,
right?
That's the term that he uses,
the fundamental idea of pagan
religion. He says, and I quote,
the idea that there exists a realm of
being prior to the gods and above them
upon which they depend
and who's decrees even,
they must obey the Metta divine realm.
This is the realm of supreme and ultimate
power. And it transcends the deities.
All right?
The DD are the deities emerged from and
are therefore subject to the laws of the
Metta divine realm,
the forces and powers of the Metta
divine realm and the nature of this realm
very from pagan tradition to pagan
tradition. It might be water,
it might be darkness,
it might be spirit or in
ancient Greek religion,
I'm a more sort of philosophical
polytheism. It might be fate.
Even the gods are subject to the decrees
of fate. They have no control over that.
Kauffman asserts, therefore this, this
belief, once you posit a primordial realm,
some realm that is beside or beyond
the gods that's independent of them,
and primary,
you have automatically limited the gods.
So what I've done is I've spelled
out here for you consequences,
logical consequences of, of positing
a Meta divine realm. You know,
once you have a a divine realm,
all of these things are going to follow.
The gods are going to be limited,
right?
They are not the source of all.
They are bound by their subservient
to this Metta divine realm.
There can therefore be no notion of
a supreme divine will and absolute or
sovereign divine will,
the will of any one God ultimately
can be countered by the decrees of the
primordial realm and the will,
the will of all the gods can be afforded
by the decrease of the primordial realm,
the will of any one God can be afforded
by perhaps another God. All right,
so the gods are limited in power.
They're also limited in their wisdom
that falls under this as well.
They're not going to be all knowing or or,
or all wise because of the existence of
this realm that's beyond them and which
is in many ways mysterious to them as
well. It's unpredictable to them too.
It's not in their control or in their
power. Individual gods might be very wise.
They might be wise in particular crafts.
Um, they might be a god of healing very,
very wise and healing or God or some
other craft or area of knowledge.
But they possess wisdom as an attribute,
not as an essential characteristic.
Koufman asserts that mythology
is basic to pagan religions.
Mythologies.
Mythologies are the lives or tales of
the lives of gods tales of the lives of
the gods.
In Pagan religions,
the gods are born and they live
lives very similar to human lives,
but on a grand scale and then they die.
They might be reborn to pagan
religions contain the agonies,
the birth of a god,
the Organi accounts of the births of gods.
Now, this impersonal, primordial realm,
Kaufman declares contains
the seeds of all beings.
Very often in these creation stories,
there is some sense of some realm
from which life begins to emerge,
usually beginning with God's.
Um,
so these come on cause my agonies and
Thiago [inaudible] will describe the
generation of sexually
differentiated divine beings.
Also the generation of the natural world,
also the generation of human
beings and animals. In other words,
this is the primordial womb
for all that is divine,
human and natural. It is a source
of everything, mundane and divine.
What that means,
Koufman asserts as that in pagan religion,
there's very often a fluid
boundary between the divine,
the human and the natural worlds.
They blur into one another because they
all emerge ultimately from this same
primordial world stuff,
right?
The distinctions between them are soft.
We see this in the fact that God's
are very often associated with natural
powerful forces, right? The,
the, the sky is a god. Um,
the fire is a god, a fertility
and natural processes that God,
so there's no real distinction between
the worship of gods and the worship of
nature. Second, he says,
because humans also emerge ultimately
from this primordial realm,
there's a confusion of the boundary
between the divine and the human.
That's common. He says he
chooses the word confusion. Um,
that's common in pagan religion.
And so we often have in pagan religions
unions between divine beings and human
beings. Kaufman argues, and I quote,
that the continuity between the divine
and human realm is that the basis of the
pagan belief in apotheosis humans
becoming gods perhaps after death,
for example,
becoming immortal or um,
very often kings when they
ascend to the throne become gods.
Whatever power the gods have Kaufman says
is not due to the fact that there will
is absolute or their spirit is absolute.
The realm that transcends the gods.
This met a divine realm is,
is that which has ultimate power and the
stuff of which it is made is what has
ultimate power.
So power is materially conceived.
It's it inheres in certain
things and certain substances,
particularly substances or materials that
are deeply connected to whatever this
primordial world stuff is.
So if it's blood,
then blood that courses through the
veins of living creatures as seem to have
some deep and powerful connection
with the Metta divine realm,
and that is where power resides. If it
is water, then water will be articulate,
will be viewed as particularly and
materially powerful in that particular
system.
Um,
so gods have power only in so far as
they are connected with that primordial
world stuff, technical term that I
use throughout this, this lecture.
That means that magic is possible in
such a system because power is materially
conceived.
In other words,
since it is believed to in here in certain
natural substances that resemble or
are connected to the primordial world
stuff, that's the source of all power.
Then magic is possible by
manipulating those materials.
Substances in certain ways. Might be clay,
it might be water, it might be blood.
Then whatever is believed to hold the
power of this primordial life force,
humans can tap into and influence the
activities of the Metta divine realm.
Um,
so through manipulation,
magical manipulations of certain
substances they can harness.
Kaufman says they can
harness these forces,
these independent self operating forces,
and so the human magician is really a
technician and he can make these forces
come to bear on even the gods to coerce
the gods to do his will and so on.
So magic in a pagan system,
Katherin claims is a way
of getting around the gods,
circumventing the capricious
will of the gods and the demons.
Because magic is directed at the Metta
divine realm trying to tap into its
powers.
It's not directed at the gods.
It's trying to tap into the ultimate
source of power to use that power to
influence the gods in a particular way
or protect oneself against the gods.
Similarly,
divination.
Divination is an attempt to discern
the future. That's once again,
heads right to the source of power.
It's not directed at the gods unless
you're hoping to use them as a medium
through which to get access
to the Metta divine realm.
But ultimately most of the nation is aimed
at and tapping the secrets and um, uh,
of the Metta divine
realm and not the gods.
Discerning the will of the gods
is really of little use, right?
Because even there will can be forwarded
or overthrown by other gods or by the
decrees of the Metta divine realm.
The Pagan cult calcium
claims is a system of rights.
I use the word cult and every
year people look at me and say,
you know what it's called?
I don't even understand what that means.
We'll learn more about cult, but it
refers to a system of rights. Okay.
A system of rights and we'll, we'll be
looking at the Israelite coat later.
So the pagan cult,
he says,
is a system of rights that involves
the manipulation of substances.
Again, blood, animal, flesh,
human flesh, precious metals,
and so on that are believed to have
some kind of inherent power, again,
because of their connection to whatever
the primer mortal world stuff may be in
that tradition.
So according to Kauffman,
there's always an element
of magic in the pagan cult.
It's seeking through these rituals and
manipulations of certain substances to
again,
let loose certain powers set into motion,
certain forces that will coerce a
god to be propitiated, for example,
or calmed or to act favorably
or to vindicate the devotees.
And so on.
Some of these cultic acts might be
defensive or protective so that the God
cannot harm. Um, the worshiper.
Many of the Celtic festivals
are keyed in to mythology,
the stories of the lives of the gods.
Many of the Celtic festivals will be
reenactments of events in the life of the
god of battle,
that the God had the death of the God.
Usually in the winter occultic rituals,
we'll reenact the death of the God,
and then in spring,
the rising or resurrection of the God.
These are all reenactment
festivals that occur very often.
And it's believed that by reenacting
these festivals in this cultic way,
one brings magical powers into play and,
and Ken in fact ensure and maintain
the reemergence of life in the spring.
And so it's essential for the maintenance
and preservation of, of world.
Um,
one final and very important point,
and we're going to wrestle with
this quite a bit during the year.
Koufman claims again in the primordial
in the polytheistic worldview,
the primordial realm contains
the seeds of all being.
Everything is generated from that realm,
good and bad.
So just as there are good gods who,
um,
might protect human beings,
there are also evil gods who seek to
destroy both humans and other gods.
Death and disease are consigned to the
realm of these evil demons or these
impure, evil spirits, but they
are siblings with the good.
God's human beings are
basically powerless.
He says in the continual cosmic struggle
between the good gods and the evil
demons,
unless they can utilize magic divination,
tap into the powers of
the Metta divine realm,
circumvent the gods who might be
making their lives rather miserable.
But what's important is that councilman
insists that in the Pagan view,
evil is an autonomous demonic realm.
It is as primary and real as
the realm of the holier good.
God's evil is a metaphysical reality.
It is built into the
structure of the universe.
That's the way the universe was made.
The primordial stuff that's spawned,
all that is spawned it,
good and bad and exactly as it is.
And it's there and it's real
salvation.
He says is the concern of humans.
The gods aren't interested in
human salvation there, uh, from,
from the capricious forces and powers in
the world because they're trying to say
themselves. You know, the good guys are
being attacked by the evil gods. Um, the,
the powers and decrease with the Metta
divine realm are hassling them as well as
anybody else. So, um, he, they
can't be worried about humans.
They're worried about themselves.
Salvation is a team as a
team through magic or, um,
gnostic means,
gnostic means gnosticism refers to
knowledge of secrets that can in some way
liberate one from the regular rules.
Um,
and so as long as one can
somehow circumvent the God,
God's Taiwan self into the powers of
the Metta divine realm to be beyond the
reach of the demons and the capricious
gods who make life on earth and misery,
that is the path for salvation.
So Kaufman says that the
pagan worldview is one of an,
a moral universe. Somewhere
around here. There we go.
A moral universe, not a moral universe,
not an immoral moral universe,
but in a moral universe,
it is morally neutral.
There are gods who are legislators and
guardians of social order and justice,
but their laws aren't absolute.
They can be leveled by the decrease of
this supreme met a divine realm. Um,
and since the knowledge and
wisdom of each God is limited,
morality can be defined as what a
particular God likes or desires.
And that may be different from
what another God likes her desires.
And there's no absolute morality then.
And it's that picture of the universe.
Calvin wants to argue that is challenged
by the monotheistic revolution again,
right? He sees this as a
revolution of ancient Israel.
So according to Koufman,
the fundamental idea of
ancient Israelite writing,
which receives no systematic formulation
but permeates the entire Bible,
and his view is a radically new
idea of a god who is himself.
The source of all being not
subject to a Meta divine realm.
There's no transcendent
cosmic order or power.
He does not emerge from
some preexisting realm,
and therefore he is free of
all of the limitations of myth.
And magic will go
through these one by one,
but a god whose will is absolute
and sovereign. All right,
so what then are the implications of the
elimination of this Metta divine realm?
All right?
They're just,
as these points flowed logically
from positing a Meta divine realm,
what flows logically from eliminating a
Metta divine realm and positing simply a
god that does not emerge from any
preexisting power or order or realm? Well,
first of all, there's no Thiago
any or mythology in the Bible.
God isn't born from some primordial wound.
We doesn't have a life story.
There's no,
um,
realm that is primary to him
were a prior to him and it's,
and there was no round. That is
the source of his power and wisdom.
So in the opening chapters of Genesis,
God simply is, he doesn't grow.
We doesn't age, he doesn't mature.
He doesn't have in the Bible,
a female consort. Um, God doesn't die.
So in the Hebrew Bible Koufman
claims for the first time in history,
we meet an unlimited God was timeless
and ageless and nonphysical and eternal.
That means that this
God transcends nature,
which means we're going to get rid
of number three as well, right?
As the sovereign of all realms.
God isn't by nature of bound
to any particular realm.
He's not identifiable as a force of nature
or identified with a force of nature.
Nature certainly becomes the stage
of God's expression of his will.
Um, he expresses his will and purpose
through forces of nature in the Bible,
but nature isn't God
himself is not identified.
He is wholly other.
He isn't kin to humans in any way either.
So there is no,
um,
blurring those soft boundary between
humans and the divine according to
[inaudible] in the Bible there.
And there's no apotheosis in the Bible,
no life after death in the Bible either.
Did you know that have to wait a few
centuries for that idea to come along,
but certainly not in, in the Hebrew
Bible, people live 70 years and that's it.
So there's no process by which humans
become gods and certainly no process in
the reverse as well.
Magic in the Hebrew Bible
is represented as useless.
It's pointless.
There's no Mehta divine realm to tap into.
Power doesn't adhere on any
stuff in the natural world.
So the world is sort of de divinized,
right?
D mythologized power isn't understood
as a material thing or something that
adheres and materials substances.
God can't be manipulated or coerced
by charms or words or rituals.
They have no power and
cannot be used in that way.
And so magic or is sin is sin.
Magic is sin or rebellion against God
because it's predicated on a whole mistake
in notion, um, of of God
having limited power.
There are magical conceptions
throughout the Bible,
you're going to run into them.
But interestingly enough,
the editors of the stories
in which they appear,
we'll very often hammer home the
conclusion that I'm actually what happened
happened because God willed it to happen.
The event occurred because
God wanted it to occur.
It didn't occur independently of his
will or by virtue of some power that's
inherent in the magicians.
Artifices.
So Koufman argues that magic in the
Bible is recast as a witness to God's
sovereignty. God's power,
um, and is stripped.
Magical actions are stripped of
their, uh, autonomous potency.
Again, they're serving as vehicles then
for the manifestation of the will of God.
Divination is also a unassimilatable
to the monotheistic idea according to
Koufman, because it also presupposes the
existence of some Metta divine realm,
some source of power,
knowledge or information that
transcends God. And again,
it's an attempt to reveal God's
secrets in an ungodly way,
predicated on a mistake.
It is permitted to make
inquiries of God through, um,
or regular devices,
but God only conveys
information at his own will.
There's no ritual or incantation.
Kauffman says,
or material substance that can
coerce of revelation from God.
So we will see things that looked like
magic and divination and oracles and
dreams and prophecy in the pagan
world and an ancient Israel.
But Koufman says the similarities,
a similarity in form only
and it's a superficial,
formal external similarity.
Each of these phenomena he says is
transformed by the Basic Israelite idea of
one supreme transcendent God,
um, whose will is absolute.
And all of these things relate to
the direct word and will of God.
They aren't recourse to a separate
science or law or body of knowledge or
interpretive craft that calls upon forces
are powers that transcend or God or
independent of God.
By the same token,
the cult Koufman says is,
um,
has no automatic or material power.
It's not just sort of a place where
certain kinds of magical coercive acts
happen. The cult isn't designed to
service the material needs of God either.
Um, it doesn't affect his life and
vitality. By enacting certain rituals,
you don't ensure that God
doesn't die and so on.
No events in God's life are celebrated,
right?
The festivals that are carried out
in the Celtic contacts context.
So the mythological rationales for cult
that you find amongst Israel's neighbors
are replaced and they're replaced
very often by historical rationales.
This action is done to commemorate such
and such event in the history of the
nation. Uh, so pagan festivals in Israel,
uh,
Koufman says,
are historicized commemorating events
in the life of the people and not in the
story of the God's life since
we have no mythology. So, um,
but we are going to be spending
a fair amount of time, uh,
talking actually about the
meaning and the function of,
of Israel's purity laws and Celtic
laws in a, in a later lecture.
Now,
since God is himself the
transcendent source of all being,
and since he is good
in a monotheistic system,
there are no evil agents
that constitute around,
that opposes God as an equal rival,
no divine evil agents. Again,
in the pagan world view,
the primordial womb spawns,
um, all sorts of beings.
All kinds of divinity is good and
evil that are in equal strength.
They're sort of locked
in this cosmic struggle.
But in the Israelite worldview of
God is the source of all being.
And there can't be around of supernatural
beings that do battle with him.
There's no room for divine antagonist of
the one Supreme God is leading us down
here to this point that sin and evil
are d mythologized in the Hebrew Bible.
And that's very interesting. It's going
to lead to a lot of interesting things.
It's also going to create
a really huge problem, um,
for monotheistic thought they're going
to struggle with for centuries and
actually still do struggle with today.
But again,
in the Pagan Worldview,
sin is understood very often as the work
of a demon or an evil God that might
possess a person might have
to be exercised from that
person by means of magic.
You know, if you tap into some of these
substances and you can use the magical,
the powers in those substances to
coerce the demon to be expelled from the
person's body,
these are things that are very common
and in polytheistic pagan practices.
But in Israel we have no metta divine
realm to spawn. These evil beings, these,
these various gods,
so Israelite religion did not conceive
of sin as caused by an independent evil
power that exists out there in the
universe and as defined the will of God.
Instead,
evil comes about as a result of the
clash of the will of God and the will of
humans who happened to
have the freedom to rebel.
There's nothing inherently
supernatural about sin.
It's not a force or a power
built into the universe.
Koufman is claiming therefore it that
an Israel evil is transferred from the
metaphysical realm built into the
physical structure of the universe to the
moral realm.
I've put it up here for you,
evil is a moral and that
a metaphysical reality.
It doesn't have a concrete independent
existence and that means that human
beings and only human beings are the
potential source of evil in the world.
Responsibility for evil lies
in the hands of human beings.
In the Hebrew Bible, no one will
ever say, the devil made me do it.
There is no devil in the Hebrew Bible.
That's also the invention
of a much later age.
And that is an important and
critical ethical revolution.
Evil is a moral and that a
metaphysical reality. You had a
great, that's what you get to
talk about. Wonderful question.
But what about when eve is tempted
by the serpent? Who is the serpent?
What is they doing? What's going on? What
does calcium and claiming? Okay, that's,
that's exactly the kind of stuff that
should be popping into your head.
What about what about,
okay.
And in section you're going
to be discussing exactly
that story. Okay. And that's,
that's, that's one of those
texts. And in a minute,
if I haven't at the end of the lecture,
ask again if I haven't kind of gotten
to a part of an answer to your question.
Okay. Um, but uh, again,
this emphasis on evil as a moral
choice. Think of Genesis for where, uh,
God warns Cain who's filled with anger
and jealousy and is thinking about doing
all kinds of horrible things. His brother
and God says, Sin Crouches at the door.
It's urges toward you, yet
you can be its master. Right.
This is a question of moral choice.
Final point then is it didn't, we're not
gonna talk about salvation right now,
but we're going to talk about
the fact that the supreme,
the only supreme law is the will of God
because God is a creator God rather than
a created God.
He's imposed order an
order upon the cosmos.
And so the pagan picture of an a moral
universe of just competing powers,
good and evil,
Kaufman says,
is transformed into a
picture of a moral cosmos.
The highest law is a will of God,
and that imposes on morality upon the,
the, the structure of the universe.
So in some Calvin's argument,
is this,
Israel conceived of the
divine in an entirely new way.
Israel's God differed from the pagan
gods in it's in his essential nature,
the pagan gods were natural gods.
They were very often associated with
line forces of nature with no intrinsic
moral character.
He says,
and the God of Israel was understood to
transcend nature and his will was not
only absolute, it was absolutely good and
more. A lot of people say, well, in a way,
didn't we just renamed them
at a divine realm? God, no.
Because the difference
here is that it's positive.
Not only that this God is the only power,
but that he is only good,
and that was not the case with
the at a divine realm, right?
That was a morally neutral,
but there's a moral claim that's being
made by the writers of the Hebrew Bible
about this supreme power.
This god God is depicted
as just compassionate.
Morality, therefore is perceived
as conforming to the will of God,
and there are absolute standards then
of justice and reverence for life.
Now,
Koufman says God is d mythologized,
but even though he's deemed mythologized,
he's not rendered completely impersonal.
He's spoken up anthropomorphically his
so that we can capture his interaction
with human beings.
This is the only way Goffman says you
can write in any meaningful sense about
the interaction between God and humanity.
So he has to be anthropomorphized,
but the interaction between
God and humans, he says
happens not through nature,
but through history. God is not
known through natural manifestations.
He's known by his action in the world
in historical time and his relationship
with a historical people just want to
read you a few sentences from an article.
Calvin wrote a different one
from the one that you read,
but it sums up his idea that there's
an abyss that separates monotheism and
polytheism and he says that it would be
a mistake to think that the difference
between the two is arithmetic,
that a polytheistic tradition in which
there are 10 gods is a lot more like
monotheism than a tradition in which
there are 40 gods because as you get
smaller number,
it gets closer to being monotheistic.
He says the pagan idea,
and I quote,
does not approach Israelite monotheism
as it diminishes the number of it's gods.
The Israelite conception of God's unity
entails his sovereign transcendence
overall.
That's the real issue.
It rejects the pagan idea
of around beyond the deity,
the source of mythology and magic.
The affirmation that the will of God is
supreme and absolutely free is a new and
non pagan category of thought.
That's an an article in the great
ages and ideas of the Jewish people.
And he goes on again to say that this
affirmation isn't stated dogmatically
anywhere, but it pervades Israelite
creativity, biblical texts.
He also asserts that the idea
is kind of developed over time,
but that basically there was a fundamental
revolution and break and then more
within that there was some development of,
of some of the latent
potential of that idea. So,
which is it? Right, which is part of
the question that came from over here.
You have on the one hand,
the claim that Israelite religion is
essentially continuous with ancient near
eastern, uh, polytheism. It,
it's merely limiting the number
of gods were shipped to one,
but it houses that God in a temple,
it offers him sacrifices and so on.
And then on the other hand,
we have Kaufman's claim that Israelite
religion is a radical break from the
religions of the ancient Near East.
Well,
the value of Calvin's work,
I think lies in the insight that
monotheism and polytheism in the abstract.
I'm not sure they exist
anywhere in the world,
but in the abstract are predicated on
divergent intuitions as systems they they,
they do seem to describe very different
worlds and therefore as a system,
the difference between Israel's God and
the Gods of Israel's neighbors was not
merely quantitative it with qualitative.
There's a qualitative difference here.
However,
when you read his work,
it's clear that he often has to force
his evidence and it rather badly,
and it's simply a fact that practices
and ideas that are not strictly or even
strongly monotheistic
do appear in the Bible.
So perhaps so scholars who stressed
the continuity between Israel and her
environment are right after all,
and this impasse I think can be resolved
to a large degree when we realize that
there we have to make
a distinction between,
well,
let's do it this way.
First we're going to talk about
a distinction between the actual,
I hate to say that as if I can somehow
show you a snapshot of what people did
3000 years ago,
but between the actual religious practices
and beliefs of the actual inhabitants
of Israel and Judah were going to
call that Israelite Judy and religion.
You know what,
somebody back in the year,
900 BCE might've done when they went
to the temple and what they might've
thought they were doing when
they went to the temple.
Cause I'm not sure it was necessarily
what the author of the book of Deuteronomy
says they're doing when they
go to the temple. All right,
so there's a difference between what
actual people live inhabitants of Israel
and Judah did.
We'll call that Israelite
Judy and religion and the
religion that's promoted or
the world view prefer that term as
being promoted by the later writers and
editors of Biblical stories who
are telling the story of these.
People will call that biblical religion,
the religion or the worldview
that we can see emerging from,
from any biblical texts.
That distinction is found in an article
and you're Jewish Study Bible and
article by Steven Geller. You're going to
be reading that later on in the course,
but be aware of that
distinction and that article,
what second Millennium Hebrews and early
first millennium Israelites or Judeans
Jude Heights actually believed or did,
is not always retrievable. In fact,
probably not retrievable to us.
We have some clues, but in all
likelihood, Hebrews of an older time,
the patriarchal period,
the second millennium BCE,
they probably weren't markedly different
from many of their polytheistic
neighbors. Archeology would suggest
that in some ways that's true.
We do find evidence in the Bible as
well as in the archaeological record of
popular practices that are
not strictly monotheistic,
the worst a little
household idols, right? Um,
local fertility deities,
for example,
most scholars conjecture that
ancient Israelite UDN religion,
that the practices of the people in the
kingdoms of Israel and Judah and the
first millennium BCE was,
it was maybe trust.
They might have promoted the
worship of one God. Yeah,
way without denying the existence
of other gods and still kept their,
their a little idols and fertility
gods are gauged in various syncretistic
practices.
It was probably monologist rather than
monotheistic really asserting the reality
of only one God.
Moreover,
our evidence suggests that
Yahweh was in many respects,
very similar to many of the gods
of Canaanite religion. And we'll,
we'll be talking about some of
those at the appropriate time.
But continuity's with Canaanite and
ancient near eastern religions are,
um,
apparent in the worship practices and
the cult objects of ancient Israel and
Judah as they're described in the
biblical stories. And as we find them in,
in archeological discoveries,
the Hebrew Bible also contains sources
that exhibit features of what Calvin has
described as contemporary polytheism.
And Genesis six,
I mean that the texts you pointed
out as a good one, but even better,
go look at Genesis six where
you have these Nuffield, Liam,
these divine beings who descend to
earth and they mate with female humans.
That's a real fluid boundary between the
divine and human realms if you ask me,
but it only happens there in one
spot in many passages to y'all.
Why is represented as presiding
over a council of Gods, right?
Certainly in the psalms we have these
sort of poetic and metaphoric descriptions
are gone. It's okay guys,
what do you think providing,
or he's one of them actually in one psalm,
it's great.
He's one of the guys and
he says, you know, you guys
don't know what you're doing.
Let me take over. He stands up in
the council and takes over. So there,
and there are other passages in the Bible
too that assume the existence of gods,
other gods worshiped by other nations,
so there's certainly stuff like that in
there. You don't have to think about now.
Nevertheless,
the most strongly monotheistic sources
of the Bible do positive God that is
qualitatively different from the gods
that populated the mythology of Israel's
neighbors and probably also Israelite
Judean religion in these sources.
Israelites,
deity is clearly the source of all being.
He doesn't emerge from a
preexisting realm. He has no
divine siblings. His will,
his absolute, his will is sovereign. He's
not affected by magical coercion. Um,
and biblical monotheism.
Biblical religion assumes that this
God is inherently good. He's just,
he's compassionate and human morality is
conformity to his will because certain
texts of the Bible posit this absolutely
good God who places absolute moral
demands on humankind.
Biblical monotheism is often
referred to as ethical monotheism.
So it's a term that you'll see quite a bit
ethical monotheism,
beginning perhaps as early as the eighth
century and continuing for several
centuries literate and
decidedly monotheistic circles
within Israelite society
put a monotheistic framework
on the ancient stories and
traditions of the nation.
They molded them into a foundation myth
that would shape Israelite and Jewish
self identity and understanding in
a profound way they projected their
monotheism onto an earlier time onto
the nation's most ancient ancestors.
Israelite monotheism is represented in
the Bible as beginning with Abraham.
Historically speaking,
it most likely began much
later and probably as a
minority movement that grew to
prominence over centuries.
But that later monotheism is projected
back over Israel's history by the final
editors of the Bible.
And that creates the impression of the
biblical religion that Calton describes
so well, right? But the
biblical text itself,
the Biblical record is very conflicted.
Um,
and that's part of the fun of reading it.
And you will see the biblical record
pointing to two different and conflicting
realities.
You will find religious practices and
views that aren't strictly monotheistic
and you'll find later religious
practices and views that are,
and the later sources, which we might
best call biblical religion, are breaking,
therefore, not only with
ancient near eastern practices,
but also with Israelite Judy and practices
with other elements within their own
society.
So biblical religion Koufman describes
it isn't I think just a revolution of
Israel against the nations.
I think it's also a civil
war of Israel against itself.
And that's an aspect that is really,
um, not entertained by Calvin.
And I think it's an important one for
us to entertain so that we can allow the
biblical text to speak to us in all of
its polyphony and not try to force it all
into one model. Right. Well, I know
this is a monotheistic text, so gosh,
I better come up with an explanation of
genesis six that works with monotheism,
you know? Okay, you're going to
be freed of having to do that.
I'm going to be freed
of having to do that.
Let the text be contradictory
and inconsistent and difficult.
Let it be difficult.
Don't homogenize it off.
So the differences between the god of
the monetizing sources of the Bible and
the gods of surrounding Mesopotamian
literature and older Israelite ideas,
perhaps, um, they're apparent from
the very first chapters of genesis.
That's a creation story.
In genesis one,
we're going to see a creation story
that's added to the pentitude pentitude,
the first five books of the Bible,
genesis through Deuteronomy.
This creation story is
added to the Pentateuch,
probably in one of the
last rounds of editing,
probably sixth century
perhaps we don't really know,
but genesis one is a very strongly
monotheistic opening to the primeval myths
that are then contained in the
next 10 chapters of genesis.
So next time we're going to start with
a close reading and examination of
genesis one through four.
We're going to read these stories with
an eye to Israel's adaptation of near
eastern motifs and themes to sort of
monitor the eyes, those motifs and themes,
and express a new conception of
God and the world and humankind.